hello everyone this next game was played
in 2006 it was the amber blindfold
tournament in Monte Carlo and the game
is played between a vastly von Schuch
and the Dutch Grand Master lock from
Valley and it was a it was an
interesting event a blind fall
tournament featuring 12 of the world's
greatest grandmasters and the world that
was won by Alexander Monro which was an
incredible nine and a half out of 11
points and he wanted with three full
points ahead of Francisco Vallejo points
and Vishwanath on Almont
so that's nine and a half out of eleven
without losing a single game on the
other hand vastly want to hear got last
place in this tournament with three and
a half out of eleven points so this is
the only good game he played well not
the only good game but the only game he
won this tournament and even
second-to-last was Lebanon and would
have a point more than anyone with four
out of eleven points so it was a weird
tournament a weird blind fall tournament
but nevertheless this game here evanka
was incredibly praised for this game so
I decided to show it it was also a
suggestion from a subscriber so let's
see this game even shook has the white
pieces and he plays efore we have c5 by
lock nine to f3 and d6
so the Sicilian defense v4c captures
Knight captures and Knight to f6 Knight
to c3 and a6 the knight or variation
Bishop to e3
now e6 and f3 the English attack of the
Scheveningen we have a Bishop to d7 now
Queen to d2 Knight to c6 event to
castles Queen side lock castles King
side and g4 event took starts his attack
on the Kings side not capture Sundy for
Bishop captures on d4 and b5 now lock
also now prepares starts pushing pushing
his points on the Queen side and it's
gonna be as usual when you have opposite
call opposite side of castles you know
who is faster whose attack happens
faster that person usually wins so if I
pushes g5 we have 937 and then now
for and here a lock plays b7 there were
some games in which before was played
but I don't know probably because it was
blindfold lock decided to go for Bishop
to b7 Queen to c7 was also an idea
instead of Bishop to b7 and you want to
place a three and this is a and this is
the movie watch was highly praised for
well among God removes because the
immediate did g6 here with the idea of H
captures on g6 and some h5 tal ideas now
you know giving up a lot of points for
the attack that happen quickly
what white does prevail if black
continues like this the problem is after
g6 black isn't interested really in
capturing H characters and g6 and this
actually leads to a to a well-known draw
and it was a well-known draw in 2006 as
well after black plays before now what
would happen is G captures on h7 would
check engage eight Knight to d5 now
offering tonight you capture Sun d5 and
our Bishop captures on g7 would check
King capture Sun g7 and rook to g1 check
now King gauge seven Bishop to h3 and f5
now Queen four rope to f6 and this was
all all known at the time Bishop
captures and I fight with check and now
King h8 rook the g7 it was known if even
the this move was known getting the
Queen into the attack with tempo King
captures on g7 Queen to g4 check King to
f7 Queen to h5 would check without King
to f8 and now Queen 288 and now
unfortunately why doesn't have any more
resources to continue the attack so he's
forced to do a three-fold repetition
King get seven and then again we need
seven king of 1887 and this was a well
known draw so now that you know this now
you can appreciate this a3 move stopping
blacks advance
for now this before move and event will
push G sets eventually rock to see 8
lakh gets the rock into the attack we
have worked the g1 Knight to e5 now
eyeing the f3 pawn queen to e3 defending
Knight to c4 now with the tempo on the
Queen here Bishop counters in c4 row
captures on c4 and now h5 and now if I
trip is definitely ready to put g6 rook
to e8 was played by lock here and this
this move really doesn't give if I took
any problems and I mean g6 is there for
the taking a more resilient idea would
be something like before going straight
straight for the attack of his own and
after something like Bishop to b6 would
attempt on the black Queen Queen to c8 a
cat or some before or capture some
before now black at least get some
counter play but Locke's idea was going
straight into you know if I took his
hand rook to e8 event to play the king
to be one first not allowing any Bishop
g5 ideas in the future pinning the Queen
to the king
so Queen the c7 now kind of kind of
blocking that night since the c2 point
is backed b3 and this is probably the
last moment Locke could have done
something to to improve on his position
lock played rook to c6 but the only real
move and a real try for black here was
rook captures on d4 given up the
exchange but gaining some counter play
after Queen captures rook the c8 now
attacking the knight on c3 rook to d3
defending in d5 now look is kind of
threatening this a3 pawn is threatening
to open up the position this
LightSquared bishop comes alive he also
has a very strong threat on the C file
and this would have been much better
than what he played about okay after b3
rook to c6 was played and divine truth
does the blindfold Knight to d5
very
and what you do here you can't really
it's not easy to decline this night he
is attacking the Queen he is attacking
the bishop if you play something like
Queen to b8 this loses tonight to f6
check and now if you're losing the the
rook anyway so you didn't really give up
anything and if you capture the Knight G
captures on f6 Queen to g5 check is a
threat followed by Queen to g7 checkmate
and if you defend this with King to f8
sorry King to h8 if you looking F a
teenage sex is mate in one so no point
in in doing this after this King h8 and
now Queen to h6 threatening Queen to g7
checkmate and after rogue defense simply
rook to g7 and there is no defense
against Queen captures on h7 and with
checkmate if you capture the rook Queen
captures in g7 is checkmate now so after
you want to play Knight to d5 lock
captured he captures on d5 and now we
have eight captures on d5 threatening to
capture the rook this is now the
immediate threat and you know if you
want to capture a rook you're done the
exchange and you're still getting
attacked so you're gonna lose this rook
captures on c2 and now if i jus pushes
g6 as black really doesn't have any move
that would help him continue the attack
of his own first he has to defend each
garrison g 6h Caterson g6 and now lock
admits that rook to e8 move wasn't
really the best idea
he plays rook back to f8 g captures on
f7 would check rook captures on f7 and
now comes Bishop captures on g7 and lock
captured that with rook captures and g7
but there really isn't a better move
here if you try something like rook to
h2 preparing Queen to c2 with Czech and
the Queen to be - with checkmate
unfortunately this loses to Bishop to e5
now opening up a discovered attack from
the rook and now you're grabbing the
rook on h2
Bishop captures on h2 you're down the
exchange and you're still getting
attacked I mean black is losing this big
time
so after Bishop to g7 a lot captured
rook captures between 36 what check was
played our King to h8 was played by lock
if King to FA this doesn't help him rook
captures and g7 threatening robbed g8
checkmate team captures and wrote to g1
and it's all over
so after a queen to e6 King - h8 was
played but now rook captures on g7 and
we have the same idea King captures and
wrote the g1 again the threats are the
same King to f8 rope the g8 is checkmate
and if King goes to h7 add the neither
Queen to g6 followed by Queen d7
checkmate or the immediate Queen to h3
would also be okay after Bishop h4 Queen
captures on h4 again checkmate but after
the other rook gave check on g1 lock-on
really resigned the game and this
beautiful blindfold masterpiece was
achieved by Vasily Evangel even though
he got last place in the tournament were
only three and a half out of 11 points
and nevertheless this is the game
everybody remembers from that tournament
in Monte Carlo of 2006 so yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon